- [Voiceover] Any shoe
you need, I probably have.
If I don't have it, I can
get it for you in 24 hours.
If you're a rapper and
you have a video shoot,
and you need the shoes
coming out in two weeks,
I just have to make a call,
and I'll get it for you.
- [Voiceover] Everyday millions of people
tune to DJ Khaled's Snapchat.
- The key to more success
is to have a lot of pillows.
- [Voiceover] One of my favorite
DJ Khaled appearances is this kid.
- [Khaled] Ben, how's
business in the new year?
- Booming.
- [Khaled] I see you.
- [Voiceover] He's 16 years
old and he's at the helm
burgeoning sneaker empire.
One that he says has done
nearly a million dollars
in business and boasts clients
like DJ Khaled and Chris Brown.
- Are you at the studio?
- [Voiceover] Meet the Sneaker Don.
- So, my name is Benjamin Kapelushnik,
people call me Benjamin Kicks,
but most of you guys know
me as the Sneaker Don.
School ends at three o'clock
and I get home at, like, four.
I eat dinner, do some homework,
and go straight to the office space.
- [Voiceover] And like any
good don, family's important.
- I'm Ben's littlest brother.
I'm his manager, so if you
need anything, call me.
- [Voiceover] Okay, not that family.
- I'm the mother of the Sneaker Don.
To me, he's my little boy,
but I also see a businessman.
He had a goal, he's self-driven,
he's motivated, he's a hard worker.
- [Voiceover] The great dons, they say,
come from humble beginnings.
- [Benjamin] The first
pair of sneakers that
actually got me in the sneaker game,
I was in fifth grade,
the galaxy pack came out,
and I got the Lebrons.
I loved sneakers after that.
Probably around sixth
grade when my parents
didn't want to fund my
sneaker hobby anymore
I had to figure out a way
how to get the money for it.
And then I realized if
I buy five or ten pairs
by paying people to stand in line for me,
I could sell it to a larger clientele
and make more money, plus
get my shoes for free.
And then it just finally broke through
and money just started coming in.
At first it amazed me how
sneakers can go for, like,
so much money for like one
shoe people are charging
a thousand and I thought it
was a, like, joke or something.
- [Voiceover] $1,000? But hey that's why
he's the Sneaker Don.
So, what comes next?
- [Benjamin] Really excited
to open up a physical store.
The first location is gonna be Miami,
and then I'm trying to do
L.A., New York, and Chicago.
All my friends, when they
dropped out of the sneaker game
they're like "It's dead, it's over,
there's no more, like,
you're not doing anything,
you're wasting your time,
you're gonna lose money."
None of the above was true.
Played themselves.
- [Voiceover] Indeed they did,
Sneaker Don. Indeed they did.
(upbeat music)